in today's video you will learn or be
refreshed about the Tom point is to grow
healthier vegetables in organic garden
organic gardening faces more challenges
in conventional gardening methods due to
a zero tolerance to harmful chemical use
but it is very possible to get a higher
yield in harvest because other gardening
methods overlook fundamental points to a
stronger crop this brings me to my first
tip nitrogen fixation nitrogen fixation
is a key building block to fertile soils
for your vegetables pods needs the
ammonia form of nitrogen for central
life components like proteins and amino
acids however they can't use a nitrogen
which makes up 80% of the air we breathe
in there for planting legumes like peas
and beans will fix nitrogen in the soil
by being stored in their nodes this
nitrogen can then be used up by other
plants require this companion plant
broad beans sugar snap peas peas and
other legumes with other vegetables and
as a result they will promote plant
growth secondly is to mulch raised beds
in the autumn with a three-inch layer of
either well watered mineral leaves or
leaf mold and cover with the dark
plastic make sure it is moist beforehand
this will let earthworms and decomposers
to work thoroughly at decomposing the
organic matter overwinter resulting in a
more fertile soil to grow vegetables in
the spring and also being warmer as per
plastic absorbs warmth ensure you poke a
few holes to allow the flow of oxygen
otherwise decomposition will not be
possible if you like to see a detailed
video click on the annotation above and
learn the steps to success in six
minutes thirdly is growing in containers
this is an especially important tip if
you have a small garden or even limit to
a balcony but growing organic vegetables
can be done in almost any situation also
people with larger gardens should strive
to include containers to grow some of
their produce in butwhy containers make
it easy to transport plants stop some
becoming invasive for example mint and
it can be used to grow vegetables and
hard surfaces for example on a patio on
a trellis which will
Aksum eyes yells containers don't have
to be plastic they can easily assemble
together wooden plant boxes or make
hanging baskets out of dowels to grow
cherry tomatoes the possibility is
endless my fourth tip is to work with
nature by attracting beneficial insects
such as pollinators or both which will
help keep pests numbers down I strongly
suggest you devote at least 10 percent
of your space to attracting beneficial
insects that is not mean to simply plant
flowers as you can still use the plants
you grow as food barrage is one
well-known flowering herb which both
attracts dozens of beneficial insects
but you can also add the leaves and
flowers to salads a colorful way to
bring pollinators is to grow a flower
border consisting of herbs of the likes
of marjoram mint and borage along with
corn flowers and buckwheat this will
create a paradise for visiting bees and
why not create a movable paradise for
example planting in a bucket or a
wheelbarrow and being able to move it
around your garden the fifth and final
tip for growing organic vegetables is to
get ahead of the game with weeds as
organic vegetable gardening is against
the use of chemical weed sprays it can
only take a few weeks to get overrun by
them weeds unfortunately will always
outgrow vegetables originally all
vegetables are weeds but after thousands
of years of cultivation they're weaker
therefore weeds will win their battle
for space but there are plenty of
methods will which will help you get
that vital step ahead of the game my
personal favorite method is mulching
using up the abundance of free resources
for example leaves cardboard and grass
clippings we can source from our own
backyard in the house or in your local
park this fall collect leaves and in the
spring you can use them to place in
between the rows of plants stopping
light to hit the bare patches of ground
and also adding nutrients as they slowly
decompose add a two to three inch layer
and repeats when you see weeds poking
through another great mulch is wood
chippings which you can get for free or
for a very cheap price at a local
sawmill black plastic is a less
aesthetically appealing method however
you get great results
when we used it on our squashes and you
can see that video by finding the link
in the description I hope you found this
video interesting and I would love to
know what your top tips are so please
post them down below in the comment
section I thank you very much for
watching and I'll see you again soon in
another video
remember don't panic and grow organic